like the reason that a low body count
matters is because historically they had
to ensure paternity so if a girl was
sleeping around like paternity tests are
new like that's a new phenomenon that
that wasn't there throughout history
they didn't want to pass on resources to
a kid that wasn't theirs the same way
like most women want a guy their height
or taller I would any of you date a guy
five inches shorter than you no two two
one two three okay
okay possible but but not common right
the most most women like if they dated a
guy shorter than them it was one to two
inches it wasn't significant and so
that's because historically you needed a
guy to protect you and you can't get rid
of that you can't get rid of your
biology